par
もうすぐ僕の一人旅が始まります日本から10時間くらいで着くんでこっちを夕方に
出ると向こうにはお昼頃に就く予定です
飛行機の中暇なのでノーベルしようと思います
ん
第2分けでアメリカにつきましためちゃくちゃ転居いいですね
留学するとまで家の方に向かいますあまさか一人でアメリカに渡ることになるとは思っ
てもなかったですね
尊重します廃墟でまで場所に行きますか
結構一括部屋なんですよは結構凄いぜ
こんな感じでございます語俳句3句スイカせず
うわぁ
整形についてしてこんな感じです3着からアメリカかー
安全にはメーカーんでしょ本当にきちゃったら辞めてから
周辺のば下がってよくわかってないんでちょっと近くを散歩してみます前ピックガード
される
us are you do これやろ砂糖
auto いろんな場所を知っただけなと思いますプレイず目指した人が多いね
もうなってるんだろうこれ見てこの回だー
ハリウッドだん
感想第的になり移れだったーー
できたらいいなと思います
あーハリウッドすげーをマジでをで今後生活していこうと思います
wh
taroo
はあなんでなんだよ
い
なんでいいの
俳優とでしょ
ついに見つけましたよ源さん
お前
はジェットができたっていうのかそうです
やっぱりハズレ再建に本音だ
でも
でも俺ああ
ロサンゼルスで3年間勉強するって決めちゃうんだ
それでも僕は
今の始めたは日本にいるべきだと思います
普段日本人を支えられ
100日本に帰りましょうヤヌア
uh
日本にはあなたを待っている人がたくさんいるんだ
それでもいいんですかああオレはー
俺はそっちでしたいことがあるアメリカに行ったら
本番急増を食べられませんよ
帰ろ
j
皆さん
嘘をついて正解でした越冬3年生に3年間ではなんてちょっと思ってしまいましたね
1週間ほど乙がにいます本当にね海外に行く機会があんまりなくてテンション上がり
すぎて
作家遊戯っていう朴ノ木物等にそういう層 to do
安定していいだろう皆さんに向かったちょっとどっち良しったげだということで
なぜきたかというと youtube の世界的にちょっと大きなウィットがあります
で雪ルポに行く誘いいただいて今回もするしております
されたです
ぶーぶー2 do ますはいいき4 p 4 k
日本テッあああああ03
日本でちょっと遠いかがわかると思いますので手元にする
てくださいおやすみなさい
2やっぱってやばいっ